So we've now confirmed not just the dates,
but also the moderators and the locations
of the upcoming three presidential debates
and the one vice presidential debate.
And Joe Biden is demanding live fact checking
during the debates, which obviously Donald
Trump will oppose.
But we're going to get to that in a minute.
There's still some debate over whether one
or both of the candidates are going to back
out.
You have some Trump ists saying Biden is going
to find a way out that Biden cognitively can't
do it.
He would be crushed by Trump's incredible
intellect and cognitive abilities.
And that Biden will find some way out.
He'll say a few days before the event that
he is Cauvin or something like that.
I don't think that that's going to happen.
I think Biden very much understands that not
debating would not be particularly good for
him.
On the other hand, there are those who think
Trump is going to try to find some way out,
either because he'd be scared that he won't
be able to do to Biden what he did to Hillary
Clinton in terms of kind of stalking behind
her and standing physically close in that.
I think that they're probably going to debate.
If I had to bet now the debates are going
to be on FOX News, C-SPAN and NBC.
CNN shut out of the debates for the first
time since 2008.
Looking at the details, September twenty ninth,
Chris Wallace will moderate a debate on Fox
News in Cleveland, Ohio.
It will have six, 15 minute segments with
two minutes per question.
We're going to get to that in a moment.
On October 7th, there will be a V.P. debate.
Susan Page from USA Today will be moderating
it.
It'll be at the University of Utah in Salt
Lake City.
It will be nine, 10 minute segments, two minutes
per question.
The second presidential will be on October
15th.
Steve Scully from C-SPAN will do it in Miami,
Florida.
It'll be a town minute format with two minutes
per question, with an additional minute as
needed.
And then lastly, the third debate will be
moderated by Kristen Welker of NBC on October
22nd.
That's very close to voting day.
Same format as the first debate.
So a few thoughts.
First of all, the format favors Donald Trump.
Anything shorter favors Trump.
And you really can't do anything in two or
three minutes.
I mean, the issues that these individuals
are dealing with are complex issues where
if you had a deep understanding of them, you
would want three to four minutes just to lay
layout that you understand the issue.
That's how you would have serious conversation.
These debates are not set up for information
purposes.
These debates are shut setup for entertainment
And the shorter it is, the more it favors
Donald Trump, because I believe it's clear.
Joe Biden is the one able to go deeper in
terms of policy than Donald Trump.
So that's number one.
Now, number two, the late debates the Trump
administration has been trying to push or
the Trump campaign for an additional debate
early this month because they recognize the
more people vote early, the fewer people left
to convince will be remaining on October 22nd.
And that's true.
I do think that on October 22nd, you're going
to have a smaller portion of the electorate,
arguably, than in any prior election due to
early voting and expanded absentee ballot
access.
That probably is good for Joe Biden in the
sense that it's Trump who is likely to pull
some kind of October surprise.
And the more people that have already sent
in their ballots or voted early, whenever
Trump pulls it, the less effective it's going
to be for him.
Now, on the fact checking, Biden previously
said he wants some kind of live fact checking
of the president on screen.
Trump's obviously against that.
It doesn't seem like it's going to happen.
And so it's going to be up to Joe Biden to
do the fact checking.
I don't need debates this year, I've said.
It's never been clearer to me who we should
be supporting.
But for those who want to see debates and
again, they'll be entertaining.
I don't think they'll be super informative.
We will be doing live streams of all for the
three presidential and the one V.P. debate.
I think the V.P. debate, Kamala Harris, is
just going to eat Mike Pence up and spit them
out.
I just don't see any way in which Pence gets
through it unscathed.
Unscathed.
His followers won't care.
They'll refuse to acknowledge it.
But I think is going to be very, very bad
for Mike Pence.